-I'm Austin Butler
and this is Working Title
-And action!
Ooh, Chatty Cathies.
-Do you have this
phrase in Iceland?
with a chatty Cathy is?
It’s like...
"Meh meeh meeh meeh"
- Women Talking, no?
-Bravo.
-Si?
-Women Talking.
-What a great movie.
-Dede Gardner.
Amazing movie.
-Irish Estrangement.
-What could that be?
-They had Irish in it
so that's a good
bloody guess.
-There’s only
one film left.
-Is it Irish Estrangement
or Irish Dismemberment?
-The Banshees of Inisherin.
Boom.
-I know what this one
would be, King of Vegas.
-King of Vegas?
No idea.
-Listen, we're just
going to start
with Baz Luhrmann
and that’s going
to be our answer.
No, no.
-That’s so good.
-It's an amazing movie
and I'm so proud
to be a part of it.
-Okay well
we all know what this is.
-In Its Entirety.
-I don't know what that is.
-Maybe...
-It's a movie
that we know very well.
-It's gotta be
-Everything, Everywhere,
All At Once.
- Everything, Everywhere,
-Boom.
-This one I don't know.
-Fast and Goose.
-It’s with airplanes,
Tom Cruise.
-Because of goose,
it makes me
think of Top Gun.
-Talk to me, Goose.
Talk to me, Goose.
-There you go.
-Günk.
Günk.
It's Günk.
It's with, like,
a weird umlaut.
-Günk.
-What is that?
-I guess Tár?
-Tár?
-We didn't
even discuss it.
-We don't need
to discuss it.
-That's the only one
I'm going to get.
-Tár!
-Tall Tale Troupe.
-Do you think
it's The Fabelmans?
-I should hope it's
The Fabelmans.
-Tall tale it’s like the
long story or a fable...
The Fabelmans!
Oh, no
you're going to get
my game show face
the whole time.
It’s The Fabelmans!
-Cat Shoes:
Making Moves.
-I'll let you.
-Is it Puss In Boots?
-Puss In Boots.
-Puss in Boots.
-Now it looks
like we favor
Puss In Boots.
That's not cool.
-We don't.
-We love them
all equally
but ours more.
-Except for Turning Red,
which is the best.
-A Wee Bit
Loud Out East?
-Out East?
A Wee Bit Loud...
Is there a noisy movie?
-A Wee Bit Loud Out East...
That’s us!
-That’s us!
-That’s All Quiet On The Western Front!
Yay, we got so lucky.
-All Quiet On The Western Front.
-Crustacean Crocs.
Crustacean Crocs.
-Scallop.
What’s a crustacean?
Mussels? Muscle beach,
no mussle...
-Crustacean Crocs.
-Sandals, Sandals Resort.
The all inclusive.
-Do that again.
-No I didn’t look.
-Marcel The Shell
With Shoes On.
-This has me stumped.
The Shape of Bummer.
-That’s the hardest one!
-Circle, square, triangle,
Triangle of Sadness.
It's Triangle of Sadness!
Why did they invite me
to this? -Yay!